we have a plentiful harvest of crazy
things to discuss today all related to
health and wealth number one um
fart girl
in the hospital this episode will be a
little late by the time the story has
been broken but understand it just
happened yesterday so we're actually the
first but by the time you're watching
this we'll probably be the last but just
keep in mind we were first
for those of you that somehow don't know
this um she's not someone from the
perverse family she's just her own
perverse person or about a month ago
we talked about the fact that she sells
jars of her own farts on only fans
for good money she was making like she
made like a quarter mil or something
like that didn't she it's like 200k in a
month selling 50
jars of farts 50 georgia farts jar jafar
remember how much people hated him
so i didn't know that she was on 90 day
fiance neither did i uh i love this here
her unusual stream of income
uh i think they could have used better
puns here whoever wrote this definitely
could have stream of income would have
been better for a like a piss king
person
[Music]
yeah she utilized her 260 000 strong
following as her customer base to st to
sell her pungent product nice which
retailed at a princely
1000 hr that's nuts i like how suddenly
every woman now farts for for so many
years it was like girls don't fart then
they see break win for it for a g uh
and now it's oh i do fart how far all
the time would you are you interested in
that because i can i can fart for a
premium i don't fart for free no more
that's so funny thinking about like two
people you know they're hanging out
girls like i have to go home
my stomach's acting up oh yeah
are you afraid to know that i that that
you that you poop that you fart in poop
oh no no no no i'm not afraid i do it uh
just not for free
come on i'm cool you can just break wind
no
no
no
you can slide me a cool thousand if you
think i'm gonna leave
these golden bricks in your toilet
now that's per so if i'm feeling like a
real rabbit and i let out like four or
five what's the what's the pt ptt yeah
price per turn yeah no pp
price per turn
we're getting that ppt loan
[Music]
can i just tell you something real fast
you bought one of her farts no but we
should do that
we should absolutely do that did we not
say that last time we did but well we
can't anymore because i mean i don't
know it depends we'll follow up on that
but we got to keep going with the story
first to figure out how like bad it is
yeah
but i'll tell you the other thing after
actually okay all right well so just
keep keeping in mind say so at one point
she was doing 50 jars of farts a week so
what's 50 divided by seven
three
yeah no like seven
no no no no it's not no it's not
seven times 749 yeah
yeah something like that you stupid yeah
seven times on who cares uh it's a lot
of farts per day
it actually it's not really like seven
yeah i mean i do seven parts a day
minimum yeah minimum i poop like four
times a day i know it's probably not
healthy that doesn't sound right i know
i know i gotta get something checked out
but that doesn't
dude i [ __ ] like 10 times a day i
actually do before my first meal i'll
[ __ ] like three times like in the
morning
are you good
i don't think so like if i'm pooping
four four or five times a day i'm
farting like way more than that yeah
dude are you just like purging like
years of
cheeseburgers i don't know what it is i
don't know saturdays are back saturdays
are back saturdays oh yeah right right
sorry stop so she said that uh she
thought she was having a stroke and that
these were her final moments that she
was overdoing it now bro she's 31 and
she would drink three protein shakes and
a huge bowl of black bean soup in one
day see you can't do that three protein
shakes a day is violent bro a 30 year
old like the third girl is listening
right now just like they felt their
stomachs flip inside not us we're 16.
whey protein is like notorious for
[ __ ] things up internally you know
what i mean and i also think that if
you're doing three and black bean soup
like that's got to give you
gastrointestinal cancer you know what
i'm saying yeah wait i didn't know whey
protein [ __ ] you up or you just mean
like makes you [ __ ] does it not [ __ ] you
up not terribly but yeah it does what is
it about the protein shake that works
for her then i thought it was like a
universally interested truth that no no
yeah it definitely i guess what i meant
was i thought you were saying like you
know in 10 years i'm gonna wake up with
whey protein cancer no no i just meant
like causing that much gas on purpose oh
yeah and you're it just means your
stomach is constantly like something's
wrong something's wrong
can't digest all this dude she retired
from selling farts because no
she had to go to the hospital
you know when she when she walked
herself in there like grabbing her
stomach one of her customers had to be
working there and he was like no no no
no
no
no no no no no dude i
oh wait are you good
no i unfortunately i think i got to stop
no no
no no no here's where the stinkiest
just give me one last one right now i
won't tell anyone
i'll set you with an iv bag i'll put you
straight into a colonoscopy just come on
just give me one plan it right here
right here give me this memory
so apparently bro she's selling these as
nfts
[ __ ] off dude hold on [ __ ] off that's
fake
that's
yeah
oh come on
mint here
oh
[ __ ] why do i want to buy one of these
things
where you go what's the floor go up
what's the floor 0.03
wait did they just come out
yeah
it's been pretty recent like as of today
or
no it was like a few days ago uh okay so
it's not not really a crazy success yet
is it
i mean you can mint for
uh
point zero five wait go
down keep going down
keep going down
that one right there that jar with the
butt hanging out yeah yeah that one's
that's the class no no go further go go
to where it says road map this should
make you feel real good about what
you're doing with your money road map
the fart jar project has no road map
hey
at least she's honest the tokens have
clear and obvious utility as mentioned
above god damn it i cannot wait
oh she's popping bubbles all right
that's that's actually really funny
though i gotta give her credit and they
don't look bad like this art is good
yeah this fart is good more like
yeah it's finally your vlog bit come
full circle
[Music]
but actually art
and fart yeah so actually it's a great
segue into what i was going to tell you
so
what's up
so
i'm getting a baby
yep
yep taking out a loan and getting a bbl
you nailed it man
you [ __ ] how did you guess that ah
you know i just was looking at you man
i've been thinking we're we're on the
same page you know
it's from years of podcasting together
that you'd be able to call something
like that out of the blue that's what i
said on january 1st i leaned over to
alina and i was like
yeah i'll make some predictions for the
year all right
i think buck's going to win the super
bowl
and uh
i think i'm going to take out a parlay
actually on both of those
things happening
bucks win cody gets a bba
[Laughter]